[Música]
bienvenidos de vuelta al espacio que
france24 le dedica al medio ambiente mi
nombre es maría clara calle y hoy
hablaremos de la contaminación por
plástico porque wwf y el instituto
alemán aui hicieron una revisión de casi
2.600 estudios para entender el impacto
que esta contaminación ha tenido en las
especies marinas y en los ecosistemas y
el hallazgo es preocupante se estima que
para 2040 la producción de plástico se
duplicaría y esto contribuiría a que los
desechos en el océano se cuadrupliquen
para el 2050 y no es sólo una cuestión a
futuro y es que la contaminación por
micro plásticos ya alcanzó sus puntos
críticos en el mediterráneo' en el mar
de china oriental el mar amarillo y el
hielo marino del ártico todo esto
significa que la cantidad de desechos
plásticos están está en los océanos y en
los mares que wwf estima que es probable
que casi todas las especies se hayan
encontrado con plásticos una de las
consecuencias es que los ecosistemas se
pueden disminuir por eso la organización
advierte que si la contaminación no se
control se podría convertir en uno de
los factores de la sexta extinción
masiva de la biodiversidad que los
científicos afirman que ya está en curso
todo esto pone en riesgo especialmente a
los arrecifes de coral porque la basura
que quedaba atrapada en ellos los
enferma y puede hacer que sus
estructuras se rompan o se desgasten y
también a los manglares pues no los deja
crecer además el estudio estima que el
88% de las especies marinas estudiadas
se vieron afectadas negativamente por el
plástico y que el 90% de todas las aves
y el 52% de todas las tortugas marinas
han ingerido plástico por eso existe un
llamado mundial para que la
contaminación por plásticos sea regulada
a través de un tratado internacional más
de 100 empresas y 156 países le están
pidiendo a la onu que en su próxima
asamblea para el medio ambiente acuerdo
dicho tratado y que sea vinculante la
cita decisiva será entre el 28 de
febrero y el 2 de marzo ya veremos lo
que allí ocurre y si a todos estos
desechos plásticos le sumamos lo que se
produjo en y el panorama es todavía peor
la organización mundial de la salud
estima que entre marzo de 2020 y
noviembre de 2021 se adquirieron 87 mil
toneladas de equipos de protección
individual como guantes mascarillas o
batas
esto es como si se llenaran más de
260.000 aviones jumbo y la mayoría de
sus productos terminarán convertidos en
basura que contamina al medio ambiente y
la situación es más crítica donde no se
separan los residuos según advirtió la
ms los hallazgos principales son que se
están generando desechos adicionales es
tres o cuatro veces el volumen de
desechos que se ha producido durante la
pandemia y en donde no se paran los
residuos ese número aumenta hasta diez
veces la ms también calculó la cantidad
de plástico que generan por ejemplo los
test para detectar el kobe 19 y es que
los cerca de 140 millones de kits que se
han utilizado en las pruebas del
coronavirus han generado más de 2.600
toneladas de plástico el 97% de esos
desechos se queman otro cálculo
alarmante es que sólo en 2020 en todo el
mundo se tiraron a la basura alrededor
de tres mil cuatrocientos millones de
mascarillas cada día ante este panorama
la organización recomienda usar equipos
reutilizables como las mascarillas n95 o
que tengan materiales reciclables o
biodegradables y mientras la industria
se acelera en ecuador hay una práctica
que intenta ser más amigable con el
medio ambiente se trata del sistema
comunitario de producción agrícola
conocido como chacras es una práctica de
los indígenas kichwa que consiste en
cosechar según las temporadas es decir
que siembran cuando hay lluvia y dejan
descansar la tierra en tiempos de sequía
así las comunidades intentan convertirlo
en una alternativa económica mientras se
enfrentan al cambio climático nuestro
corresponsal gustavo ortega nos cuenta
la historia
lupita es una mujer indígena que
practica un método de producción
agrícola conocido como la chacra es una
forma de cultivar cacao frutas y
tubérculos en parcelas familiares
protegiendo los guajes que habitan y
reduciendo el impacto de los suelos
tenemos nuestro chacra para llevar los
alimentos a la casa como estamos
apoyando a nuestros maridos estamos
apoyando como con la yuca con el plátano
con la guayusa con la vainilla con los a
las aves del campo lo que está que tal
expertos en técnicas de cultivo educan
sobre cómo generar dinero con los
alimentos sembrados a lupita y a su
comunidad un negocio que va acorde con
el cuidado del medio ambiente porque la
chacra respeta los ciclos productivos y
le da descanso a los suelos sin destruir
grandes extensiones de tierra o generar
deforestación esto nos ha permitido
bajar la presión la presión de la
frontera agrícola sobre los bosques y se
va adaptando a lo que ellos necesitan
no es una economía
mercantilista sino primero la soberanía
alimentaria de las familias y ahora como
ingresamos al mercado es ahí justamente
lo que estamos articulando
[Música]
267 indígenas que practican en la chacra
decidieron unirse en sociedad 66% son
mujeres la idea de asociación surgió
para que los alimentos que producen
también se puedan vender en el mercado
de
la ciudad versión alta parroquial para
llevarme al email para mis hijos pipita
que conoce la importancia de mantener la
riqueza de la naturaleza en momentos de
crisis climática quiere traspasar a las
generaciones futuras el conocimiento de
esta práctica ancestral que contribuye
con la finanza de los lugares indígenas
y con el cuidado de la amazonía
ecuatoriana
y así llegamos al final de nuestro
programa los invitamos a que vean más
sobre medio ambiente de nuestro canal de
youtube y también en nuestra pagina
france24 puntocom nos vemos próximamente
[Música]